YURI GRINSHTEYN: We've seen
how to use OpenTelemetry
to instrument our services
for both distributed tracing
and custom metrics.
But what do we do
when tracing shows
us there's a latency issue
in a specific service?
That information
is often in logs.
So today, we'll go over how to
bring logs and traces together
into a single view,
using OpenTelemetry
and cloud trace and logging.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
Let's take a look at an
example app written in Go.
It receives a user request,
does some internal processing,
then makes a back inquiry
before returning a response.
Using OpenTelemetry,
we can create
trace bands that will
capture the timing of each
of those actions.
If the internal processing
step takes a long time,
we want to use logs written by
our app to diagnose further.
The good news is that it's
possible to automatically
create associations
between traces and logs.
We just have to the write
the idea of the trace
and span into the payload
of your log entries,
and cloud trace and
logging will do the rest.
But what do you get those?
Well, first, let's review some
basics about how distributed
tracing works in OpenTelemetry.
You can refer to the official
documentation for more detail.
We'll link to that below.
A trace is essentially the
sum total of information
we want to collect
about the user request
as it traverses our
distributed system.
A span is information about
the request and response of one
of the services in our system.
Spans include span context.
This is the information
that must be propagated
with every request that
allows the tracing library
to reconstruct the entire
trace when all requests are
completed.
Finally, Go provides
its own context
for request and
distributed systems
that contain information
about request propagation.
We'll use all of
this information
to identify our traces
and spans and connect
them to log entries.
Now let's dive into our code.
This is the function we'll
use to write our log entries.
There are two main parts here.
In the first part, we
extract the information
we need about the trace and
the span from the context.
Note that there
are two steps here.
We get the span from
the request context,
then extract it's span
context, and finally
use that to get the
trace ID and span ID.
In the second part, we
use that information
to construct our log entry.
We write the log payload and
add the trace and span ID
information to it.
Here's what our log
entry looks like when
it's written to cloud logging.
Notice that it
contains information
about the trace and span ID.
Finally, when we go to trace,
we can see that our trace now
includes log entries.
We can use them to
better understand
exactly what's happening if
one of the spans in the trace
shows a latency issue.
Using OpenTelemetry to
connect traces with logs
is a great way to improve the
observability of our service
and make latency issues
much easier to debug.
That's it for this episode.
Thank you for watching, and
come back soon for more.
This is The Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]